this is modafinil it's the smart drug or
nootropic that everyone is calling the
real limitless drug
what does actually do and should you be
using it anyone who's seen the film
limitless or read the book for dark
fields that the films based on will be
familiar with what's a nootropic is in
theory basically is any supplement or
medication that's supposed to enhance
your cognitive ability make you think
faster make you more creative make you
more focused in this case with ethanol
is a supplement was originally designed
to be used by people suffering from
narcolepsy that's a condition where you
fall asleep randomly so the main idea
behind it is to keep people awake and
stop them from falling asleep and that's
one of the main ways that people use it
they use it to prevent themselves
falling asleep feeling tired so they can
be productive throughout more of the day
what people have also found though is
that it can be used for a range of other
benefits these include increased focus
improved concentration and several other
things depending on who you ask many
businessmen athletes and other people
claim to use with ethanol and say it's
actually somewhat responsible for much
of their success sprinters use modafinil
because it gives them a better reaction
time off the starting rock so they start
quicker when the gun fires there are
lots of new tricks out there and a lot
that are commonly used by students and
businesspeople etc but modafinil
especially one of the most pronounced in
terms of the effect and that's why it's
not completely legal in every country
over here in the UK you can get on
prescription if your night shift worker
or if you have narcolepsy that makes it
a little bit more risky but it also
makes think that maybe it actually does
something as compared to some of these
other things
piracetam is another popular one but
person they haven't felt much benefit
from that what this also means those of
course it's risky and I wouldn't
recommend anyone else using the deaf no
I gave it a go just for a journalistic
integrity because I thought of making
interesting articles and health sights
and for the pioneer so I can review it I
have had mixed results with it
and I said
recommend it let's talk about what those
results were like essentially being on
modafinil you're not going to feel the
effects like in the film luminous you're
not going to suddenly be awoken to this
more colorful and amazing world it's a
bit of disappointment from that regard
much like most other nootropics and most
bodybuilding supplements if I - instead
what you'll find is it's a bit like
taking a lot of coffee you feel kind of
jittery at the same time is focused and
hiding able to concentrate you don't
need to eat as much you'll go long
stretches without eating partly because
you're so in depth focused on what
you're doing you're getting toilet more
often colors seems slightly more vibrant
which is something quite interesting but
of course these effects will depend on
the dosage you take and what the best
messages will depend again on who you
ask
but the main effect in terms of
cognitive enhancement is the
concentration and you find yourself
really focusing on one thing in fact I
found that I almost couldn't see what
was around me it was like I had a kind
of tunnel vision I'd be looking for
words at exactly what I was looking at I
wouldn't notice things in my peripheral
vision as much as I normally would
saying with thinking I could fall
completely into my own thoughts and
actually not hear other people saying to
me which I would think is actually quite
dangerous you know you won't want to
cross the road whilst using the devil if
you're thinking about a maths problem
then you will probably get hit by a
truck so in that regard that's a plus
and a minus you want that kind of focus
if you are sat down in front of your
computer you have no distractions and
you're working hard on what you're meant
to be doing that day but just as you can
get stuck working solidly on what you're
supposed to be doing if you get
distracted say start playing Sonic the
Hedgehog you'll be just as focused and
addicted to that thing so you're staring
so headshot not thinking about anything
else you almost can't break out of this
repetitive behavior it's very
interesting I found it interesting as
well in terms of problem solving this
kind of immense focus let me really
think get inside my own head and mull
over a problem I was asked to make multi
screen multitasking better when I was
producing it some Indian develop some
Indian manufacturers they produce mobile
phones and they wanted my app to come in
built onto their phones they asked me to
improve some aspects I thought were
impossible I have to work
tonight so I've tried another modafinil
and I found myself actually coming up
with a solution fairly quickly straight
after I've taken it one night I woke up
in the middle of the night
scroll down with these notes like an
insane person on how to create a program
that would write articles for me this is
something to be working on for a while
but I was just I came on leaps and
bounds from just thinking about that now
that might sound good to you but as you
can imagine I didn't sleep that well
that night because I was up here writing
I would often go lots of nice when I was
using it just thinking over things I'm
not sleeping properly I actually got
quite tired and my body was clearly
exhausted my workout suffered as a
result and because my body was so much
more amped up because my metabolism was
faster I felt kind of chesty achy you
know how if you drank three big cups of
coffee you wouldn't quite feel ready to
do a workout because you feel like
you're trembling too much I felt like
that a lot of the time and that's the
thing I was using it more often because
I was having these good results I
thought I should be using it more often
I'd pump out more words for my writing
clients account with better programming
solutions and I made some better apps so
of course a temptation was there to use
in the death-knell at the same time that
I was then too focused in my own head
couldn't switch off wasn't really
engaging with the world around me was
losing sleep stopped working out
properly
it was almost and it has this other side
effects as well my eyes were sometimes
bloodshot I would bite my mouth and my
lips I was using it too much but the
thing is I never intended to use it -
you might have intended to use it once
for a review I have an addictive
personality but it's clear that this is
a potentially addictive substance and so
I really wouldn't recommend it to anyone
and it's addictive chemically I believe
probably but I also think it's addictive
psychologically because you know you
could do better on it so why wouldn't
you use it it was only when I started to
realize on my workout for suffering I
was getting tireder but I decided I
needed quit it some other interesting
effects were a bit like the limitless
film I found myself hiding or becoming
more organized and these are things that
have actually stayed with me since I
came off it which is quite interesting
and potentially benefit it's a bit like
the ending of the film I tied in my room
my Hg
the assistants bought at a paper tray
redesign my brog and all these things
I continued you're interested in
creating more order around myself but at
the moment I kinda seem to have the best
of both worlds of what the energy I used
to have and at the same time I've got
some good order and structure again I
don't recommend them and it could go
either way couldn't it could go horribly
wrong but it is interesting to think if
you use a nootropic you're not just
going to get the benefits right then
you're forging new neural pathways
you're repeating those neural pathways
cementing them in your brain so you will
have some leftover effects afterwards
order those it's a bit good or for the
bad it's the same with bodybuilding
supplements and with steroids even again
I don't condone steroids and they use
those myself but if you're using
steroids to build a bigger muscle your
muscle in the teens it's not muscle
memory that's a misnomer that many
people use your muscle retains the
ability to grow again more quickly and
easily afterwards so again it might not
be great in the short term but there is
an interesting after effect that's maybe
worth considering you know for science
not for us it also brings up some
interesting discussions about creativity
and the nature of creativity because
when I was using this modafinil
my eye was so much more focused on one
thing and so much more able to
problem-solve but actually in terms of
pure creativity they say that not
stimulants like modafinil but more
depressant like alcohol actually better
for creativity one because it allows me
to sit back take a step back to let the
brain search all the connections
all the disparate ideas that volumes
with head during the day and forties
when you connected with new ideas that's
what many people think creativity is the
more relaxed you are the more able you
are students more your brain wonders as
you become more focused your body
produces more adrenaline and that keeps
you focused on just one thing stress
mixing papers yes generally and these
things have that creativity obviously
both the Me's we want purpose where
you're writing and creativity ideas you
need to learn to relax five years and to
amp yourself up become free to get work
done
however drugs and luckily I sir there's
many other ways brain training is
exercise diet all these things have a
much more complex and actually the very
best nootropic in the world is sleep
sleep through your world adapting
doesn't really help with that so the
death knell very interesting experiment
has actually had some beneficial effects
on me if you think about the native
creativity is resulted in a very
interesting program working life would I
recommend it definitely not because if I
wasn't able to quit I think would have
got worse and worse it was expensive and
eventually I don't know where could have
ended up so yeah thanks for sticking
with me thanks for watching if you found
this interesting please click follow or
like or whatever on youtube and stick
around check out my blog to pioneer I
know that I try to reboot everything
much before but this time I think I've
got it right this is the new format I
hope you like it
as usual there'll be videos on here
about fitness working out diet health
plan also venturing a little bit further
into my other interests self-improvement
working online technology so if you're
interested in expanding your mind
through training technology as my
tagline goes then stick around and
please come back for more yeah I hope
you like the slightly more professional
attempt I'm going out here a few less
tangents and jigs
they'll still be some of that but yeah
I'm trying something a bit different
please let me know what you think in the
comments thanks a lot see you next time